Our typical assumption on workspace qubits is that they start out in the zero state and we can often return
them to the zero state
when we're done with them, but not always.
In the diagram we have a cat zero inside of the dotted rectangle to indicate that the
initialization of this qubit
is part of the process, and if you don't have a
fresh qubit like this, you're not gonna be able
to do this simulation.
The bottom output qubit
is the one we care about because that's the result
of the AND operation and we're basically
done with the other two
so they can stay inside of the box.
In fact, you could even imagine that getting rid of these two qubits is part of the job of
simulating this AND gate,
kind of like garbage that
needs to be cleaned up.
But anyway, that's how we
can simulate an AND gate.
Now that we know how to do AND gates, we can do OR gates using
one of the De Morgan laws.
If you put NOT gates on the two inputs in the output of an AND
gate, you'll get an OR gate, so it's as simple as that.
And the last one is FANOUT, and for this one, all we
need is a controlled NOT gate along with a workspace qubit.
Specifically, if we
set the workspace qubit to be the target, we effectively just copy whatever standard basis state comes in,
so that acts like a FANOUT gate.
So we have all our gates.
And now that we have all of our gates, we can move on to circuits.
Let's suppose that we have
some Boolean circuit named C, and this can be whatever
Boolean circuit you choose
as long as it's composed of
AND or NOT and FANOUT gates.
We'll let T be the number of gates in C and we'll give the name F to whatever function it is that C computes.
So we can think of F as having the form that you see right here, where N is the number of input bits of C,
M is the number of output bits and sigma is the binary alphabet.
And what we do is to simply go one by one through the gates of C.
We leave the NOT gates alone and we replace the others with the simulations
that I just described.
So if C looks like this, then what we get is a circuit
R that looks like this.
In this diagram, all
of the workspace qubits we need for the simulations have been pulled out of their boxes and collected on the bottom.
So K is the total number of
workspace qubits we need, which is one for each of the gates of C except for the NOT gates.
For the output of R, we have the qubits that
correspond to the output of C, and here those qubits
are depicted on the top,
although it's not actually going to matter at the end of all of this
whether they're on top or not.
To be precise, assuming that we've run R on a standard basis state corresponding to an
arbitrary N-bit string X,
these M output qubits will be in the standard basis state
corresponding to F of X.
We also have all of the leftover qubits from the AND and the OR gates.
We still need to account for them, and if we gather them all together, they'll be in some standard basis state.
Whatever the standard basis state is has to be some function of the string X, and we're gonna give
that function the name G.
So G is a new function that's
determined by the gates of C that tells us what state
these leftover qubits are in
after R is run. G is the next letter after F, so that's one reason to
call this function G,
but another reason to call it G is because G is short for garbage.
These are all garbage qubits, and in particular, we
have two garbage qubits for each AND gate and for each OR gate.
The total number of gates
we need is big-O of T.
That's because for each gate of C, we need a bounded number of quantum gates.
The OR gate is the most expensive one. For that one, we need three NOT gates along with one Toffoli gate,
and a Toffoli gate costs us 15 gates from our standard gate set.
So that's at most 18 gates
in R for each gate of C.
If you wanted to optimize this, you could, but for the purposes of a
rough asymptotic analysis, we can simply say that
R has big-O of T gates.
So we've managed to
compute the same function F that the original Boolean
circuit C computed,
and we've done this at a cost that's linear in the size of C.
If all we care about is
computing this function F, then we're done.
But unfortunately, we do
have these garbage qubits and these garbage qubits
are generally going to ruin
the interference patterns that make quantum algorithms work if we try to use this
circuit R as a subroutine
inside of a larger quantum algorithm.
But we can in fact get
rid of this garbage, and the way that we can do
this is to make use of the fact that the circuit R can be inverted,